[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قال المبعوث الدولي الى ليبيا
برناردينو ليون ان الامم المتحده تشجب
باشد العبارات الغارات الجويه التي شنتها
صباح الاربعاء قوات تابعه للواء متقاعد
خليفه حفتر على مطار معيتيقه الدولي في
اثناء وجود وفد المؤتمر الوطني العام
للحوار في المطار نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقشه في محورين ما دفع حفر لاستهداف
وفد المؤتمر الوطني للحوار وما دلاله
الحزب الذي ابدته الامم المتحده ازاء هذا
التصرف
وما هي خيارات المنظمه الدوليه للرد على
المحاولات المتكرره لتعويض الحوار
والسيناريوهات المحتمله في حال فشله
[موسيقى]
بحسب وزير الخارجيه الايطالي باولو لوني
الذي لم يستبعد تدخل عسكري في ليبيا في
حال فشل الحوار من اطراف الازمه فيها فان
مقترحات المبعوث الدولي الى ليبيا
برناردينو ليون عن الحوار تكشف عن تفاؤل
كبير بامكانيه تحقيقه اختراقا مهما في هذه
المرحله تفاؤل قد يفسر يفسر بنظر البعض
الحزم الواضح الذي واجه به اليوم محاولات
اطراف ليبيه تعليق الحوار عبر استهداف وفد
المؤتمر الوطني العام في اثناء توجهه الى
مقر الحوار في مدينه السيارات المغربيه
ليست المره الاولى التي تفعلها قوات حفظ
تستبق جولات الحوار بالقصف وتستهدف على
الاخص مطار القريبه من العاصمه يحدث هذا
بينما يكون وفد خصومها ائتلاف القوى
المنضويه تحت لافته المؤتمر الوطني العام
يتهيا للسفر وهو ما دفع المبعوث الاممي
الخاص برناردينو ليون للخروج عن مالوف
تعبيراته الدبلوماسيه وندد بما اعتبرها
رسائل السلبيه موجهه للحوار نفسه ولا فتن
هنا ان جماعه حفتر لا تنكر فعلتها تلك بل
تؤكد ها وتدريجها في سياق محاربتها لما
تصفه بالارهاب والحال هذه ما هي خيارات
اليوم ليس سوى المضي في الحوار حاليا وقد
دخل مرحله حاسمه على حد قوله ففي الجوله
السابقه توافق الفرقاء على وثيقه مبدئيه
حول تشكيل حكومه وحده وطنيه
ومجلس الرئاسي وترتيبات امنيه ومن المقرر
ان يواصل البحث والنقاش لاقرار ذلك في
الجوله الحاليه واذا حدث وتوافقوا فان
ليبيا تصبح امام مرحله جديده قد تدفع قوي
وتحالفات الى التراجع ومن تم الخروج من
المشهد كله اذا خلصت النيات امر يفسر في
راي البعض اصرار حثت او مناصريه على
التصعيد ثنائيه برلمان طرق والمؤتمر
الوطني العام في سبيلها الى التفكك وكذا
المؤسسات التي انبثقت عنها وتحديدا تلك
التي اقرها البرلمانيون المجتمع في طرق
والحكومه التي شكلها من تلك مناصب منحت
وقوه حشدت واسلحه شحنه بهدف وحيد وهو
القضاء على من باتت توصف بجماعه طرابلس
لكن هذه الجماعه نفسها حسب الخطاب المسكوت
عنه للمبعوث الدولي برهنت انها الاكثر
التزاما بالخطه الامميه للحل المفترض في
ليبيا اكثر مواضبه على حضور الحوار الذي
يتم برعايه اليوم كما انها الاكثر تصديا
لتيارات متطرفه تنشط في سرت وسواها تحت
مسمى تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
فقد سبق لقوات في ليبيا ان اشتبكت وقاتلت
مناصر التنظيم هناك في معارك تكررت وخلفت
العديد من القتلى بينما تبدا جماعه حق كما
افاد التسريبات الاقرب الى اللعب بهذه
الورقه كما بورقه فلول القذافي لا لمحاربه
الارهاب الحقيقي بل اتخاذه ستارا لتحريض
المجتمع الدولي ودول المنطقه على خصومها
وهم منتخبون كما تقول الوقائع و منخرطون
في سياق الحل الدولي ما يضع المبعوث
الدولي امام خيار الوحيد ربما في مقبل
الايام
ادانه حفتر ومن والاه وربما رفع ما تبقى
من شرعيه دوليه عنهم
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
الصخيرات المستشار السياسي لوفد المؤتمر
الوطني العام صلاح
ومن العاصمه الاردنيه عمان محمد انور
الكاتب الصحفي الليبي المقرر بمجلس النواب
ومن نيويورك عبد الحميد الصيان الكاتب
الصحفي المتخصص في شؤون الامم المتحده
ومتحدث سابق باسمها اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا
مع محمد انور ما الذي يجعل قوات حفر
تستهدف هؤلاء قبيل المؤتمر
نعم اهلا وسهلا اولا لا يوجد اي تصريح
رسمي من قبل رئاسه اركان القوات الجويه اه
بالجيش الليبي
يعني تثبت ان هذه الغاره الجويه على موقع
في مطار او قاعده امريكيه في طرابلس هي اه
من تنفيذ
سلاح الجو الليبي كالعاده يعني عاده ما اه
يعني تعلن رئاسه الاركان السلاح الجو اه
هذه العمليات
وتنسبها
لنفسها ولكن هذه المره اه لم نسمع حتى هذه
اللحظه ان رئاسه اركان السلاح الجوي تبنت
هذه الغرب وبالتالي انا اتوقع وبصفه صحفي
متابعه للشان الليبي ولا استبعد ان يكون
الطرف الاخر وهي قوات فجر ليبيا هي التي
اه قامت بتنفيذ هذه ال ال العمليه حتى يتم
اه توجيه الانظار الى الطرف الاخر واتهامه
من قبل المجتمع الدولي ولذلك كان اه اليو
ناو بيان للامم المتحده حريصه او حذر نوعا
ما اه اتجاه هذه الغاره وبالتالي لم يحدد
الجهه المسؤوله عنها وطالب ايضا بكشف
الاسباب للمجتمع الدولي وراء هذه الغرب
فيما اذا كانت اه فعلا اه من ورائها ال اه
سلاح الجو التابع للجيش الليبي
كان يعني ربما شاهدا على مسار السيد
ماركوس يقول
محمد انور قد يعني لم يستبعد ان تكون
تجريبي بذلك
نعم ا اعتقد ان ما يقوله ضيفك الكريم
مضحك ويدعو الى الشفقه السفراء هنا قالوا
بانهم يعرفون انها اقامه بذلك ولكن
لاعتبارات دبلوماسيه لا يريدون التصريح
بذلك ولكنهم حثت الاطراف الدوليه على
تقديم تقارير بهذا الشان للامم المتحده
وكما هو الحال ايضا اه يعني فجر ليبيا
تقصف هذا الوفد وهو في الطائره الطائره
تتحرك على المحضه على وشك اه مغادره الارض
اقلاع جول ومن ثم يبدا القصف علينا هل
تعتقدين يعني للحظه واحده ان هذه القصه
التي يرويها لدى الاسطوره مثل ضيفك من اه
اه من الاردن اه صحيحه اعتقد انها نوع من
الاستخفاف
بالمشاهد العربي الذي يشاهد هذا البرنامج
اريد ان اسالك كما قلت هو متحف ومستخف اذا
كانت سريع قبل ان انتقل الى ضيفي مليار
نعم ال ال المضحك هو اه توجيه الاتهامات
دون اي ادله والمضحك ايضا ان يقول ان
او في الامم ذكر لك اولا اولا تنكر قالت
ان صحيح القصف حصل وهذه ليست المره الاولى
التي تقول صحيح قد تحصل خاصه انه في
السابق اه كانت تبرر ذلك بمحاربتها بما
تسميه الارهاب وثانيا برناردينو اليوم
اكثر من مره المح الى ان هؤلاء لم يلتزموا
بما طلب منهم
ودبلوماسيون في خيارات اقرب يعني سموه
بالاسم من هو الطرف المعرقل ان الادله
نعم الادله انه لا يوجد ادله ال ال
الطيران اه سلاح الجو اه في الجيش اللي
بيستهدف مواقع اه اه يعني تشكل خطر على ال
اه على ليبيا وبالتالي لا يستهدف طائره
تقل المتحاورين الى ال الى المغرب الى
الصخيرات وهو قبل يوم واحد من هنا من عمان
قال في تصريح لاحدى الوكالات العالميه
بانه لا يمانع من الحل السلمي ولا يمانع
من الحل السياسي ولكن اذا استعصى الحسم
العسكري هو ال ال القادم يعني هناك تناقض
حقيقه اه ار اه اه في في في هذا المشهد
وبالتالي لا لا لا اتفق مع ما قاله الضيف
قبل قليل طيب هناك عبد الحميد صيام اه
هنالك موقف واضح من الامم المتحده ازاء
هذا القدس اعود الى ضيفي المسيرات لكن
اريد ان اتوقف عند موقف الامم المتحده مما
جرى مع معك سيد صيام
نعم كان السيد برناردينو ليون واضحا قال
فقد نفذ صبر الشعب الليبي وقد نفذت صبر
المجتمع الدولي وادان هذه العمليه دون ان
يحدد من الذي قام بها لكنه طالب بال
بالحرف ان يكون هناك تحقيق واضح وشفاف في
من قام بمثل هذه العمليه لانه قد يكون
يعني هناك احتمال ل لطرف ثالث يريد ان
يعطي هذه المفاوضات لكن اه اه منطقيا الذي
سيخسر جزءا من سيادته وقوته في هذه
المفاوضات اذا نجحت قد يكون في وضع قلق
لانه اذا ما وصلت هذه المفاوضات الى شاطئ
الامان واتفق الجميع وخرج هذا الاجتماع من
السيارات باتفاق شامل
واه الاتفاق على الحكومه المؤقته الوطنيه
الشامله التي تشمل جميع الليبيين والنقطه
الثانيه وهي موضوع الاتفاقات الامنيه وقف
اطلاق النار وسحب المسلحين
فهناك بالتاكيد كما قال برنار دوليون
بالحرب الكل ان ياخذ كل ما يريد الكل يريد
ان يقدم التنازلات اذن هناك اطراف ستخسر
بعض مواقعها ستخسر بعض من قوتها ستخسر بعض
من اه ال ال الوضع الذي التي وجدت نفسها
فيه الاعتراف الدولي ربما تكون في وضع قلق
وبالتالي تريد ان تعطل مثل هذه ال اه
المفاوضات ولكن كان هنالك حديث السيد
الصيام ربما سمعت عنه اه ما كان قد المح
الى ان هنالك طرف معين يعرقل وهنالك طرف
في المقابل والمؤتمر الوطني يلتزم اكثر
بالخطه الامميه كان هنالك يعني حديث موفق
بالصوت والصوره اه للمسؤول عن يتحدث عن
ذلك
نعم اه يعني هذه ليست المره الاولى هناك
كلما كان هناك جلسه حوار يتم اه اه اتخاذ
خطوات استفزازيه
لاضفاء اجواء توثر على جلسه المفاوضات او
ل اه دفع الطرف الاخر بان يعيد مراجعه
مواقفه من هذه المفاوضات لكن الجميع يعرف
انه لا يوجد امامهم خيار من جهه من جهه
اخرى الجميع يعرف ان
التي تدعم هذا الطرف او ذاك ايضا
موجوده في صف الامم المتحده و تدفع باتجاه
انجاح هذه المفاوضات لان لا خيار امام
الشعب الليبي لخياره الا ان يتفقوا والا
ستنهار ليبيا وستتحول الى الصومال ثانيه
وسته تصبح دوله فاشله
وينتظر فيها الارهاب سريعا
لو اخذنا اليوم تصريح حبر ما ردينه اليوم
الذي ادان باشد العبارات هذه الغاره ويعني
كان خطابا جديد لتشديد ربما على انه يجب
هذه الغارات لم يكن في السابق بهذه الحده
او بهذه ال ال الاهميه بهذا التشديد
واضفنا اليها تصريحات سابقه تلمح تلمح الى
من هو الطرف الذي لا يلتزم الخطه الامنيه
هل نتوقع تحرك اما من الامم المتحده ضد
هذا الطرف اي قوات حفر ومن يقف وراءها
ام
اه السؤال كنت اظن ان السؤال لاحد الضيوف
الاخير
عن هذا الموضوع
الامم المتحده ما زالت تراهن ان الاتفاق
في متناول اليد صبر كثيرا وتتحمل الى ان
توصل الاطراف الى اتفاق الان بين يديهم
ويعتقد وتعتقد الامم المتحده ان هذا
الاجتماع حاسم جدا وسيخرج باتفاقيه هذا ما
تتوقعه الامم المتحده لكن اذا فشلت هذه
المفاوضات ربما تكون الامم المتحده في وضع
افضل ان تشير باصبع الاتهام الى من يعطل
هذه الاتفاقيات ومن يحاول ان يعرقل جهود
المنظمه الدوليه و مبعوثها الخاص السيد
برنامج يوليو نعم السيد
اذن اه اه كنت تودي ابداء ربما ملاحظه ما
على كلام محمد انور اه طريق الفرصه سريعا
قبل ان نتحول الى فاصل قصير نعود بعده
اليكم تفضل
نعم
نحن نريد ان نقول ان هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يقصد فيها عثر فريق الفريق
المفاوض قبيله او بعيد اه اقلاع هذه المره
الخصوصيه هي انه الفريق في الطائره
والطائره تتحرك وجاء هذا القصف والجميع
يعرف من يخسر ولكن اه يجب ان ان ان نقول
بان اه ما ذكره اليوم السيد ليون في
اجتماع معه قال بان اه من يقوم بهذه
الاعمال
يعتقد بانه سيخسر في اي اتفاق ليبي وعلى
هذا الاساس يجب ان نقول بان اي اتفاق يحصر
هنا هنا في الخيرات سيكون الفائز فيه اولا
واخيرا الشعب الليبي و سيفوز البرلمان
وسيفوز المؤتمر الوطني و ستفوز فجر ليبيا
الخاسر الوحيد بوضوح هو حفر اذ ان مشروعه
لاستنساخ نظام السيسي وانقلاب السياسي في
ليبيا سيفشل فشلا تماما وهو وضح بكل وضوح
عندما قام بانقلابه انه يريد تجميد
الاعلان الدستوري وحل
ال السامه التشريعيه وانشاء مجلس عسكري
اعلى وعلى هذا الاساس هو يعرف جيدا بان اي
اتفاق سيحصل في خيرات سوف يقضي على هذا
المشروع الى الابد اتوقف مع فاصل قصير
مشاهدينا الكرام نناقش وبعده خيارات الامم
المتحده لحمايه الحوار بين اطراف الازمه
ليبيا وايضا نناقش خياراتها اذا فشل نرجو
ان تبقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اه من جديد ومباشره الى محمد
انور سيد محمد اه انور باعتقادك هل هنالك
اه
مجال من قبل قوات حفر للتراجع الان او
لتقديم تنازلات بالنظر الى ان هنالك قد
يكون هنالك خيارات امام امام الامم
المتحده ان فشل الحوار بتسميه من هو
المعرقل وقد تسمي هذا التراث الطرف الذي
يعني اه
يعني تشرح لنا وجهه نظره
اي قوات حفر اه انا لا اعرف اسمه وقوات
حفظ ماذا تقصدين
لا تعرف ما هي قوات حفظ
طيب اما سيد صلاح بمثلك يعني اه يصلح اكثر
منه لكي يشرح لك من هي قوات حفظ ويشرح لك
ايضا اه ما الذي يجري في ليبيا وربما
لاحقا لا نستضيفك كونك غير مطلع على الملف
سيد ثمانيه قوات حفظ لو سمحت حتى يستوعب
سيد محمد انور من عمان
وقوات حفظ كما يعرف الجميع هي القوات اه
وليست قوات ولكن مجموعه من الضباط الذين
اه
جمعهم خليفه حفتر
لاقامه مشروعه وما يسمى بعمليه الكرامه
ومن ثم بعد تحركه العسكري اه ارغم برلمان
طرق على تبنيه ورق اه من رتبه عقيد الى
رتبه لواء الى رتبه فريق اول وضمه الى ال
ال تحت جناحي البرلمان وسماه بالجيش
الوطني الليبي وعلى هذا انهم يقولون الان
بانه هو الجيش الوطني الليبي والجميع يعرف
الجميع يعرف بان هناك انقلاب اه في تلك
الجهه غير معلن ولكنه لازال يستخدم
البرلمان ك ورقه توت من الشرعيه يتفضل بها
ويتجول بها ويريد ان يكون له الان حصه في
هذا الاتفاق وعلى هذا الاساس اعتقد انه
يعرقل العمليه التفاوضيه للوصول الى ربما
موقع يسمحوا له بالتموضع كما
علي عبد الله صالح
يعني حتى فقط نوضح الصوره للسيد محمد انور
ولا يتهمنا هنا باننا تبني عبارات او اه
التوصيفات هل هناك اجماع على تسميه هو
يريد ان نسمي هذه القوات ربما في الجيش
الليبي هل هنالك اجماع في ليبيا على تسميه
هؤلاء بالجيش اللي بها للكل المزمع على
ذلك جرى استفتاء هل هنالك مؤسسات فعلا ومن
ضمنها مؤسسه الجيش الليبي
هنا ليس هناك ما يسمى بالجيش الليبى الذى
يسميه حفتر الجيش الليبي الجميع يعرف
والخبراء يعرفون بان ليس لدينا مؤسسه
متكامله تستطيع ان تصنع حربا او تقوم
بعمليات او ما الى ذلك او تعبئه اه ب
بالمعنى المعتاد ما هناك في الشرق الليبي
هو مجموعه من الضباط الذين جمعهم حفر واه
الان على سبيل المثال في محاور مدينه
بنغازي في محاور مدينه بنغازي من ما يقارب
واحد وعشرين محور اه ما تسمى ب قوات الجيش
الليبي متواجده في اقل من اربع محاور
الباقي هي عباره عن صحوات او عباره القوات
المتواجده في هذه المناطق اشكرك السيد بوش
على التوضيح واتمنى ان يكون السيد محمد
نور اطلع اكثر على الملف الليبي السيد عبد
الحميد صيام ما هي الخيارات المنظمه
الدوليه الان للرد على هذه المحاولات
المتكرره ل تعليق الحوار
يعني كما قال السيد برناردينو ليون في
كلمته ان هناك فرصه الان وهذه فرصه
تاريخيه لن تعوض وهو ما زال يراهن على اه
وطنيه الليبيين جميعا وعلى اه الضغط
الشعبي الليبي كما قال لقد وصل صبر الشعب
الليبي الى درجه الصفر لا يحتمل اكثر يريد
حلا لهذه الازمه ولكن لنفرض ان الحوار لم
يصل الى منتهاه وان الاتفاق الذي موجود
بين ايدي المتحاورين لم يصل الى اه ال ال
ال الوضع النهائي
وانهارت ال المفاوضات فما هي خيارات الامم
المتحده واريد ان ادخل في هذا الموضوع
يعني نتمنى ان لا نصل الى تلك الخيارات
لكن هناك ثلاثه خيارات اعتقد من تجربتي في
الامم المتحده ان ممكن للامم المتحده تتبع
احد احد هذه الخيارات الثلاثه او لا خيار
الصومال ثانيا خيار البوسنه والهرسك
وثالثا خيار الكونغو وال اه سيراليون
وليبيريا الخيار الاول الصومال وهي ان
تنفض يدها الامم المتحده وتقول انتم لستم
مستعدين للوصول الى اتفاق هذه مسؤوليته
مسؤوليتكم قاتلوا انفسكم كما تريدون سنخرج
من هذه المعمعه ومن هذا الوضع اه ال
الفوضوي اما الخيار الثاني وهو الدعوه بل
قوى خارجيه ان تدخل كما حصل في البوسنه
والهرسك عندما تدخل الناتو وهو مستبعد
الان تماما لان لا يوجد هناك اه من جهه
معينه تريد ان تدخل قوات الناتو مره اخرى
الى اه الى ليبيا الخيار الثالث وهو
المعقول ايضا ان يكون هناك قوات اتحاد
افريقي بمباركه امميه بقرار جديد من مجلس
الامن ودعم من دول اوروبا المعنيه وخاصه
دوله مثل ايطاليا وفرنسا وبعض الدول
العربيه لايجاد قوه اه اخرى تدخل في ليبيا
وتحاول ان تفرض سيطرتها
وتوجد مناطق عازل او مناطق امنه يبدا اه
الليبيون الغيورون على وطنهم ينتمون الى
هذه المناطق ويتم توسيعها الى ان يتم
اعاده ليبيا الى الشرعيه الدستوريه والى
اه اه حاله الاستقرار كما حدث في سيراليون
وفي اه الان في القوات الموجوده في
الكونغو ودارفور وجنوب السودان والى اخره
التي تصدرها قوات الاتحاد
محمد انور ما الذي يمكن ان يكون عليه موقف
مجلس النواب في طرق من كلام وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي الذي قال في بوضوح في حال فشل
الحوار الذي ترعاه الامم المتحده ستكون
هناك حاجه اه اه لتدخل عسكري في ليبيا
لحتى مكافحه الارهاب هناك ما الذي يمكن ان
يكون عليها موقف مجلس النواب برايك
نعم اه اولا ساجيب على السؤال س تجاوز ما
صدر من كلامك متوتره يعني وانا عذر كان
واضحا اه
السؤال للسيد صلاح حتى لا ندخل في اه
مسائل شخصيه هنا ويعني حتى لا نبتعد
بالحوار عن عن به سيد صلاح حول اليك نفس
السؤال عن انه في حال اه كان كلام وزير
الخارجيه الايطالي جديا ما الذي يمكن ان
يكون عليه في المقابل اه موقف المؤتمر
الوطني اه في هذا الشان
انا اعتقد ان الخيارات التي يطرحها السيد
صيام وما يقوله اه وزير او رئيس الوزراء
الايطالي هي خيارات غير واقعيه واعتقد انه
سيحدث امرا اه اه اه احد امرين اما ان
تتبع الدول الغربيه
وهو اعتقد مستبعد سياسه امنيه تعبر عن ما
يسمى بال كنت ين من
المشكله وترك الليبيين في الداخل يتصارعون
مع بعضهم البعض اه مع اه توفير ما يكفي
لعدم خروج هذا الصراع خارج الحدود الليبيه
او ان وهذا هو اعتقد ما يعبروا عنه الجميع
هنا على الاقل من السفراء الاجانب انهم
سيحاولون مره اخرى اه الوصول الى اتفاق
وسيستمر الحوار واعتقد ان الاطراف الليبيه
الجاده وهناك اطراف جاده اه في كل ال ال
المعسكرين اه تريد الوصول الى توافق
واعتقد ان الشعب الليبي يريد ان يصل الى
توافق ايضا وقد ساهم اه هذا التشبت الذي
يبديه اه برلمان طرق بانه هو ال ال السلطه
الشرعيه الوحيده مع ان الجميع يعرف انه
دستوريا سينتهي حتى لو اه لو وضعنا حكم
الدائره الدستوريه جانبا فانه دستوريا
ينتهي في شهر اكتوبر القادم بعد خمسه اشهر
سؤال للسيد في نيويورك عن هذا الموقف
الايطالي الى اي حد يمكن ان يكون جديا
مساله التدخل العسكري في ليبيا بالنظر الى
ان ايطاليا اول واحده ربما تخاف على
حدودها لوقف الهجره من تسميهم الارهابيين
صوب اراضيها وصوب اوروبا الى اي حد يمكن
ان يكون هذا الاحتمال وارد وجديا وقريبا
برايك
انا اعتقد انه احتمال وارد اذا ما كان
هناك قرار جديد من مجلس الامن يشرع مثل
هذا التدخل لا اعتقد ان ايطاليا ولا فرنسا
يمكن ان تتدخل دون شرعيه من مجلس الامن
لكن بالتاكيد المجتمع الدولي وخاصه اوروبا
وعلى راس اوروبا ايطاليا لا تريد ان ترى
ليبيا دوله فاشله
تتحول الى بؤره للارهاب وتصدير الارهاب
واه اه هجره مئات الالوف من المهاجرين غير
الشرعيين الذين يغرقون في المتوسط كما حصل
يوم امس عندما غرقت السفينه وتوفي اكثر من
اربعمائه شخص لا يريدون ان تكون تتحول
ليبيا الى مثل هذا الوضع الماساوي شكرا
جزيلا لك ضيفي من نيويورك عبد الحميد صيام
الكاتب الصحفي المتخصص السوري المتحده
المتحدث السابق باسم الامم المتحده وايضا
اشكر السيد صلاح
وقد حدثنا النصيرات وهو مستشار السياسي
لوفد المؤتمر الوطني العام و اشكر من عمان
محمد انور و اشكر متابعتكم الى اللقاء
ام
[موسيقى]